you're in another film at the moment
silence martin's christianity's film and
was it you went to wales to prepare for
that was it yes wales wales yes
no because you you're a monk in the film
yeah a priest a jesuit priest yeah so um
part of that preparation was
um myself and adam driver we both played
these jesuit priests and
it's set in the 1600s in in japan where
christianity has been outlawed it's very
it's an amazing film i'm certain and
it's a martin scorsese film and acer has
worked with ma with with marty and he's
he's made up something quite profound
but but but one of the the things that
we did was we went on a silent retreat
in wales at a place called saint bynos
which is a beautiful christian retreat
house do you know about it well it's
very beautiful i've haven't done the
retreat thing
too early for that
and yeah so we had about eight days
together in in silence me and adam we
met each other once in new york and we
had a drink and and then we met each
other again in wales in in total silence
for seven days so did you say hi as you
went in no it was it was like it was
like a mime it was just all mime and
mouthing did you do lots of
like that was a lot of that it was
[Laughter]
like
do you write notes i mean you must speak
at some point during eight days no you
don't you really don't has it has anyone
ever done that has anyone ever done a
silent retreat
not one person they can't tell you about
it
i found it to be a beautiful experience
yeah gorgeous and i i very quickly got
used to
my own
company and not having to uh i don't
know just it creates a real intimacy
with yourself
um what's it like when you get out then
we lost our minds it was it was
this is the weird thing we got into a
car together
and we had a three-hour car ride to the
airport um together
and it was just this torrent it was just
this outpouring of the most vile
language and imagery i don't know it was
as if the devil
suddenly went where have you been for
the last seven years
you bastards
and and suddenly it was it was the most
vile it was it was really scary it was
genuinely frightening
and giggling and kind of like crying
with laughter but but then anyway we
ended up having the most disgusting
wonderful conversation
[Music]
you